tiny little LeBron James just came out
that's alright dinosaur why is there no
poop emoji okay
let me explain that's me looking like a
total nutjob and that's magic leaps
much-hyped augmented reality nerd
goggles I mean magically it's one
creator edition a few weeks ago I went
down to sweaty Florida to the company's
headquarters I strapped on the new
headset and it's computer fanny pack and
saw some pretty incredible things that
blurred the real and digital world only
one little problem you're watching this
video on a 2d screen which means I can't
show you all the awesome things I was
able to see plus the company didn't let
me record what I saw through the headset
all they gave me were these short
marketing clips who is that guy anyway
but fear not
I can draw sort of yes I decided to draw
what I saw during my experiences with
magic these aren't virtual reality
goggles virtual reality blocks off your
real surroundings and takes you to a
different reality augmented or mixed
reality glasses like magic leaves still
let you see the real world but place
digital objects in it so you may have a
ugly pet sea turtle or a virtual TV how
does magically do that well that's where
the hype comes in the company has raised
more than 2.3 billion dollars on the
promise of its light-filled technology
that digitally mimics the light hitting
our eyes from the outside world the
light we're headset has two special
lenses that lets you see the real world
plus virtual 3d images it uses cameras
and other sensors to track walls and
flat surfaces and even watch your hands
so digital objects can interact with
them at times these objects actually
looked solid the soft pads inside the
headset make it surprisingly comfortable
to wear and even after wearing it for 30
minutes tensed I felt fine
the light wear is connected to the light
pack a mini
on your hip that helps power the whole
thing the controller is your new-age
Mouse it's how you navigate the menus or
shoot robots coming out of the wall so
you get what it does but what would you
use it for remember those doodles are
how I remember it what I actually saw
through the headset looks more like this
everything is hyper realistic and closer
to video game graphics right now tiny
little LeBron James just came out and
dunked in this tiny little hoop the
future of watching sports or news or
even your favorite Netflix show could
look like this okay so I've got a
dinosaur here it's like Barney but like
not as friendly this beautifully drawn
dinosaur could be any object and could
be used in educational or professional
environments right yeah there's a chair
floating in the room and then there's
the future of shopping I actually pulled
this 3d chair off of a special version
of wayfair.com
which loaded in magic leaps web browser
compared to microsoft's hololens and
certainly phone based versions magic
leaf has the best technology I've seen
when it comes to melding the digital and
the tangible these are real chess pieces
right
but the $2,300 headset is nowhere near
ready for the masses not in substance
nor in style how long till they're in
these I can't say exactly what but
that's the that's the goal that we need
to get to even today in our labs we're
working on driving down the size of this
that's our explicit goal for the next
version of the hardware that's our goal
is to make it smaller and smaller until
then magic leap is something you're
gonna want to try out whether through
your early adopter friend or the pop-up
stores the company plans to launch in
the coming months you'll be able to get
a peek at the future and buy future I
mean you know dinosaurs you just told me
he wants hot dogs for lunch
you
[Music]